you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to part 2 of the three part
series of the rise and fall of Nakia
previously we saw the man who started
Nokia and the circumstances that forced
Nokia to become a communications company
after this who began to see how they
started prospering within the industry
in today's episode we'll look at how
they rose to power and what innovations
they brought to the table some of them
last till this very day let's continue
the 1990s were a special time for mobile
technology the general population could
keep in contact with each other for the
first time and a lot of this was due to
Nokia's diverse range of innovative
indestructable phones that everyone just
loved but at this time the difference
was there was no selfie obsession
Instagram Facebook didn't even have to
charge a phone that often the 90s of the
golden decade for Nokia as it had now
streamlined its focus to mobile phones
only let me take you through a nostalgic
look at Nokia's rise to industry
leadership even if you're not into
technology it's kind of interesting I
want you to think of this as a company
charting brand-new territory paving the
way in an infant industry that was to
eventually become the world's largest
for the time the Nokia team had great
insight and intuition as you'll soon see
the first milestone arrived in 1992 in
the form of the Nokia one zero one one
this was the world's first GSM digital
phone for those of you wondering the
acronym GSM stands for global system of
mobile communications and it is still
the standard used today
the first gsm networks were 2g which
were replacing the old analog 1g systems
after this innovation nokia really began
to find a groove and they showed that
they could push the concept of an
all-encompassing Dordogne mobile phone
that was more than just a simple
transmitter and receiver connected over
a network they knew and I mean knew that
the future was all in the software with
adequate easy-to-use software this new
phenomena of a portable talking device
could be so much more this revolutionary
idea was finally realized in the Nokia
2110 released in 1994 and it was kind of
a big deal at the time
mobile phones were still huge and bulky
with large batteries yet they still had
very small almost unreadable displays
when the sleek device came to market
people was stunned the 2110 pretty much
went all the way it had address books
missed call and text indicators and it
was the first phone to feature that now
familiar nokia ringtone which was
composed over 100 years ago by the way
and not only that it was one of the very
first phones to be able to both send and
receive text messages the 2110 was an
absolute smash hit and went on to become
one of the best selling phones of all
time and because of this it pretty much
defined the way a business phone should
look but that wasn't all Nokia was just
getting started and the importance of
software was fully realized in 1996 with
the Nokia 9000 communicator
it took IBM's 1993 concept of the smart
phone even further by adding a full
QWERTY keyboard web browsing email fax
word processing and of course the 90s
quintessential spreadsheet the only
problem with this device was that it hit
the market too early in many respects
people couldn't relate to the aspect of
a northern one encompassing phone
800 dollar price tag also didn't help
but to knock it over all that didn't
really matter because by this stage they
were on fire in 1997 Nakia released the
61 10 this was the first phone to ever
feature the most legendary mobile game
ever made snake
the 61 10 also had an advanced user
interface that was to become the
industry standard it's kind of the same
equivalent importance as the home screen
on your modern smartphone today by 1998
Nokia overtook Motorola as the number
one phone manufacturer in the world but
during this same year a significant
event occurred that would help shape
Nokia's destiny it was a mobile
operating system you see Nokia was
really into the software side of things
and they believe that having an active
role in software development could be
beneficial for the company so they got
on board with a software called Symbian
even though Symbian was heavily used by
Nokia it wasn't their sole creation
Symbian originated from epoch an
operating system created in the 1980s
Symbian was actually a major joint
venture between Ericsson Motorola and
Nokia themselves after this Symbian
split into different platforms for
different mobile phone manufacturers
there's a version built by Nokia for
Nokia Samsung and LG phones and there
was another version for Sony Ericsson
phones and Motorola phones the Symbian
operating system was actually quite
advanced for the day but actually later
proved to be a real thorn in the flesh
for Nokia there'll be more on Symbian in
the next part ok back to the story of
Nokia and their incredible innovative
streak by 1999 Nokia was absolutely
smashing it and the Nokia 3210 was the
bombshell this phone actually
accommodated for consumer consumption
with multiple covers it also featured
pre-made to turn picture messages such
as a happy birthday that could be sent
by SMS it was also very cheap which for
the first time meant that was available
to ultra tech savvy teenagers born in
the 1980s
remember mobile phones at the time was
seen as mum and dad's work communication
tool and for the first time the 3210
made technology cool and sociable Nokia
had officially reached almost every
market and absolutely incredible feat by
any means
in the early 2000s Nokia just had hit
after hit with phones such as a 5110 in
the year 2000 and the 1100 in 2003 again
one of the best selling phones of all
time 2002 was a particularly good year
for Nokia as they released the 66 50 the
world's first 3G phone and also the 76
50 Nikias first ever camera phone which
incidentally was featured in that Tom
Cruise movie Minority Report
I guess the movie directors knew that
camera phones are going to be the next
big thing from 2003 Nokia really began
to experiment with different designs and
as it turns out experimentation and
winning streaks don't always go together
and hence Nokia's first major mistake
occurred in 2003 a bit of context first
during this year games in general were
pretty hot the ps2 and Xbox were just
hitting their prime time and the Gameboy
advanced us blew the portable game
market open just the previous year
Nokia wanted in so what did they end up
doing well they ended up taking a
slightly revamped LCD panel and modified
a phone designed to feature directional
keys as well as a full phone dialer and
they launched the infamous end gauge and
just by looking at this picture of it
you can see a few problems it generally
would have been clumsy to use either as
a phone or a gaming device simply
because of that design and button layer
any multi-purpose product has to perform
all of the advertised features well and
this just didn't cut it in late 2004 the
u.s. manufacturer Motorola scored a
worldwide hit with it's very thin razor
flip phone Nokia got a bit of criticism
from its investors and they were saying
that they spent too much time on
high-end smartphones while rivals ate
into the lucrative business of selling
expensive dumb phones to people around
the world but despite this in 2005 Nokia
phones became so popular but they were
the number one digital camera brand
worldwide but it still wasn't enough
Nokia in their management the market for
dumb phones proved to be too attractive
and because of this Nokia's financial
officer Olli Becker colossal took over
from the management mindset of mr. alia
in 2006 the new management merged
Nokia's smartphone and basic phone
operations now it was all about the
bottom line
instead of Nokia leaving basic phones
behind and moving ahead they focused
more on the traditional phone nokia went
backwards frankly this change of
management marked the beginning of the
end for Nokia's amazing run in the next
episode we'll see the inside information
from previous staff members during
Nokia's faltering days surprisingly one
of the major reasons for Nokia's fall
was from within
Nokia would become played with internal
company conflicts which made them very
slow in reacting to Apple's release of
the iPhone and subsequently Android
release it's actually pretty interesting
to see what went on behind closed doors
anyway that marks the end of this
episode thanks for tuning in and
watching but before I leave I just want
to leave one fun fact you may have
noticed that all the Nokia codes for all
their phones never really have the
number 4 in it and that's because in
Asian markets the number 4 is seen as
unlucky by some people so I just thought
that was quite interesting anyway thanks
for watching don't forget to leave a
comment thumbs up and subscribe if
you're new this has been to gogo and
you've been watching cold fusion I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
have a good one guys Cheers cold fusion
it's me thinking
you